[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
really excited to be talking to you all
about the life of an interlocutor
[Music]
Oh pumped pump for this one pump for
this one for a multitude of reasons
because I myself AM an interlocutor and
I'm excited to express to you what it
has been like learning to become an
interlocutor and I think it's important
to start with the definition the easiest
definition for an interlocutor is one
who partakes in dialogue that's it as
simple as that
one who partakes in dialogue move with
that roll with it great let's do it
so just one who partakes in dialogue so
this can be on stages this can be on a
show this can be on you know you
partaking in dialogue with your parents
and your friends but this is a very
profession to me it's a become a
profession so I literally do this every
single day so it's slightly different
for me because it's become a profession
in that sense so alright there's a lot
to unpack I have some cool notes for us
I'm excited to share with you a really
good analogy for being an interlocutor
is playing tennis and tennis is like
it's like mine tennis is what it is so
it's like hitting back ideas with new
spin doing things like steel Manning
let's explain a couple of these things
okay so you know for those that don't
know I'm Alan Saki and I host this show
simulation and so we sit down with all
these thought-provoking leaders and
they're all from different fields and so
you have to be able to play really
strong game of my tennis back with them
as you're hosting them on the show and
so I'll get to the reason why being a
polymath an empath together and
combining those two things is really
important for building out this really
strong mental lattice for being able to
play be a really good tennis player and
so hitting back ideas with new spins so
when you get sent over an idea rather
than just being binary with the idea or
rather than just just moving on to the
next thing or not even asking them a
question about it so you have to know
how to ask them a question when you get
hit the tennis ball back you
maybe you know do you get hit the tennis
ball you want to add an idea or a
thought to it send it back to them and
maybe you're even adding a question to
it and so by doing that process you're
actually really working on creating a
very strong game of intellectual tennis
between you two and I really like that
analogy is really fun so another really
crucial part is steel Manning and I have
it highlighted up there right now and
steel Manning there's a there's a pretty
easy way to understand what it is so I
talked about this in the TEDx talk and
that links in the bio as well the TEDx
talk on powerful questions that I gave
two months ago
so a very easy way to understand steel
Manning is to first understand straw
Manning as well so straw Manning is when
you take someone's idea and you
misrepresent it so that you can easily
beat it a lot of people strawman
nowadays and steel Manning is when you
take someone's idea and you make it even
better and you show to them that hey I'm
listening to you I'm paraphrasing your
idea and making it even better the
person sees that you care and you're
listening and then furthermore you can
then aim to augment their perspective by
saying do you see how that doesn't work
or do you see how it works you know so
it makes for better conversation when
you steel man versus straw man and then
so you got to really be able to
calculate you have to be you have to
have very strong cognitive capabilities
so and up to as much extent that we have
so basically one of the ways to
understand what what intelligence is is
intelligence in many ways is one's
ability to abstractly reason and
calculate with tons of different
variables at the same time and
synthesize that into through cognition
into what comes out of our mouth into
another person's mind so into
conversation so that in some regard is
the better you are at reasoning with all
of those different abstract variables
that calculate into a conversation with
someone else the more you are able to
have a good game of tennis and be a
stronger interlocutor with them so
develop out your mint
lattice and make it really
multidisciplinary and Polymathic and
we'll get to that and that way with
again is just the limitation right now
soon it may not be a limitation because
we will have the addition of neural
laces connecting us to the infinite of
of knowledge and then things change a
lot and you know our hesitations on that
ethical hesitations on that we've talked
about now on a couple of our episodes
but that will increase on our limited
cognitive capabilities down the line
okay
on we go to being a polymath an empath
this is extremely important and maybe
the most important thing out of this
entire conversation I've been teaching
it for a long time a super long time and
so what I'm what I'm doing is I've been
for the last three years now mentoring
in Silicon Valley mentoring
entrepreneurs across different
organizations and shout out to
organizations like Indy bio the largest
biotech exciter in the world or like or
like founder Institute one of the
largest founder accelerators in the
world and Draper University and hacks
and all these different orgs that I've
had the chance to work with and I'm
telling you if you become a polymath an
empath it helps you so much in life
because you're building out a more
robust and multidisciplinary mental
lattice so that way you can talk with
anyone about anything almost and on top
of that when you build out the empath
side of things you can really tap into
another person's emotional state and be
able to relate with them on a very deep
level and when you can relate to them
when you can ask them good questions and
show them genuine care and love and eye
contact that that whole process will
amplify your ability to execute whatever
you want into the world and build
relationships win friends influence
people it will help you so freaking much
so smashing those two things together
are really multidisciplinary a mental
lattice and a really strong connection
to other people's hearts and knowing how
to properly do that is so so important
and I've been preaching this to
entrepreneurs
for the longest time now and so build
out your mental lattice and this is
extremely important parse for the
greatest signal because this happens all
the time we we too often accidentally go
for what's noisy and if you want to be
an interlocutor you got to go for the
signal if you want to be anything in
this world you got to go for the signal
because the second that you follow the
noise you end up losing noise is the
antithesis of execution noises the
antithesis of signal it's just it's so
bad and so parsing again applying the
Pareto principle so important here so
that means doing things like seeing that
only 80% of all of the knowledge that
exists in the world is noisy and only
20% of the knowledge that exists in the
world is actually signal signal E so
that means things like when you're on
Wikipedia whatever is important to you
about art or entrepreneurship or some
sort of science or some sort of
spirituality or whatever you're doing
you have to find the things that have
the highest signal-to-noise and parse
for those things and go learn from those
disciplines and watch those content
creators that are at that have the most
signal and that's a wean to do what this
channels have the most signal and have
the least noise and we try our best to
do that there's a ginger tea by the way
it's so good we just literally boil
ginger it was so good all right so so
it's once one thing that I noticed with
the Hawthorne effect was that it was
really hard to get people on board of
Vaud casting as an interlocutor so
people are totally willing to have
conversations with you but they're not
necessarily willing to have those
conversations with you when they are in
front of a camera and so I think that
that's extremely interesting because it
means that maybe they have some sort of
an asymmetry going on in their life
where they will not
what they preach on camera but they will
in private settings which i think is an
asymmetry and it may not actually be
necessarily healthy and so so analyze
people why are they not willing to go on
with vodcast thing well I think people
get a little bit weird with that you
have to get used to it but once you get
used to it it becomes really easy and
plus it's a big part of our future for
many people you have to know how to
communicate in these different mediums
either video either audio excuse me or
writing so you have to get really good
at one of those mediums and so you know
even like you take a photo you slept
like right about it you know that's like
you gotta get good at these different
mediums and this is something that you
know gary vaynerchuk's been teaching for
a while
and i really like the way that he
teaches about it and you know get really
good at something one of these mediums
of communication all right moving on to
this parts also kind of interesting if
you look at someone like Joe Rogan who's
who's who's done vodcast enlike a sport
he's become an interlocutor as a sport
he literally goes live multiple times a
day and he understands that content is
king and he's been doing it for nine
years now and he's done I think a
thousand two hundred and like 20
episodes or something and that is
absolutely nuts because when you've that
that is that is mastery that he is
mastery you know he is the definition of
mastery in the interlocutor field and
there is a lot of other people that can
work their butts off to aim to be
mastery in the field as well and I think
that over time they will because vodcast
thing is only growing and becoming
better but certain people only vodcast
once a week where some people only
podcast with audio or some people only
write a blog whatever you know it's
there's too many smart people on the
planet too so to be able to sit down
with them more often and actually have
long-form nuance driven conversations
extremely important and that's what we
aim to do and so you got to publish as
many of these thought-provoking podcast
as multi-disciplinary
leaders and public intellectuals on the
planet we that's extremely important to
us and highlighting it right there for
you to see and provide as much signal as
possible over all the noise that's on
the internet that's such a crucial point
for us that if you it's just gotten so
egregious there's so much noise on the
Internet so making as much signal as
possible onto the Internet is crucial so
post only the most interesting things
that you can think of that will inspire
other people in some way it can be a
picture of food say why it's interesting
why is this food interesting it can be a
picture of something you made why is the
thing you made interesting add lots of
noise to the intr add lasari lots of
signal to the interwebs and parse
through all of the information so you
can find the greatest signal as well so
that's a little bit on the life of an
interlocutor smash together being a
polymath and being an empath smash those
things together like it's no one's
business get really damn good at having
a strong multidisciplinary mental
lattice and also being able to get to
people's hearts and showing them that
genuine care in love and getting really
good at those two things and play these
amazing games of tennis with people and
have fun as you have the opportunity to
live these 80 years on this rock and
advance to the next level all right much
love everyone thank you for tuning in I
greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you also go check out the
rest of the links on the bow give us a
subscribe follow us give us a like on
the video and thank you everyone go and
manifest your destiny into the world go
and build the future you know how to do
it actually go execute put down the
Netflix put down the YouTube channel put
down the beer garden invitations from
your friends and go and build build the
future I love you all thank you for
tuning in and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]